I would say family or friends
or any any kind of business partner
relationship the best thing I would say
the best thing that you can do and is
the hardest to do is to communicate
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with Brandy Merrick Brandi
spent most of her career in management
and Leadership roles at Magnolia Gardens
Nursery a family business with over 150
employees as a Next Generation family
member in a family-owned business Brandy
understands the delicate and at times
challenging situations that can face
family businesses Brandy has experienced
developing strategic plans leading
departments and managing Capital
expenses she is comfortable with
complicated financials and the nuances
of organizational structure however her
passion lies with the people
organizations Excel when the people
within them Thrive and Brandy is driven
to bring out the best in people
[Applause]
I'm really excited to have you here you
may see me look down from time to time
I'm taking notes on my notebook I found
that it helps me and learn as well
[Music]
I'm in the listening seat right now and
so yeah thank you thank you for being
here
um you know today we're going to be
talking about your own Journey but also
family businesses in general and like I
mentioned to you I know very little
about you know the complexities and
challenges that arise in family
businesses I may be able to postulate
some of them but you're going to uh to
share with me your own perspective with
myself and the audience and so even
before we get to that Brandy why how are
family businesses intertwined in your
own life as a part of your own career
well it's it's two different ways now
um but it all started when I started
working in my husband's family business
um about 15 years ago it's a Wholesale
Nursery so it grows out plant material
for large commercial landscapers and
also retail garden centers things like
that and then we also have a tissue
culture lab that help
plant breeders bring plant genetics to
the market so I really that's where I
got my start but I'm now a family
business advisor with Ferguson Alliance
and we help family businesses so think
either businesses that are owned by a
family are operated by a family or just
a privately held business so we don't
work with anybody that is in any kind of
private Equity or anything like that
um so we help family businesses
figure out what's next as you mentioned
it's very complex it can be very nuanced
and you say that you don't know much
about it so I'll just say the next time
you're like either planning a vacation
with your family or maybe the holidays
or something like that
um now just imagine that's what you do
every day and it's to generate revenue
for your well-being and then you will
better understand how complex and
complicated it can be
um trying to navigate challenges like
that with your family
it's fun it can be very fun but it is so
personal and so it gets very challenging
at times
so right yeah yeah I mean I'm just uh
you're leaving me pondering you know I
was I just got back from from a month
with my family abroad so I can so I'm
already you know the the wheels are are
flying
emotional emotional personal Revenue
business all those words combined it's
sort of like taking this uh this uh old
uh
don't mix business and pleasure but just
like ripping it apart and saying no
that's exactly what I'm gonna do tell me
a little bit about first of all
motivations for doing that what what are
the different circumstances that we find
around the world families engaging in
this behavior and and and then we'll get
into some of the more challenges and how
how we can start resolving these these
difficult challenges that I yeah I'm
clueless right now about well just as it
is in in my example and then also in
every client that I've worked with it
all starts with someone having a vision
right they either have an idea that is
going to dramatically improve life or a
product that's going to improve life
something they feel passionate enough
about that they take the risk of opening
up a business that's always how it
starts they feel passionate about
something and they want to provide for
the greater good they want to provide
for their family they want to provide
for other people's family so it all
starts all all of our clients have these
amazing starter stories of how of how
they began and then
those Founders go and they have children
and they all have this dream that their
kids are going to want to carry on their
legacy and their their business and so
that's really that's where it began it
always is founded in something amazing
so how much of the time do you find a
family business was
took took place as a part of a family
business rather than a regular business
because it made sense logistically and
financially versus it came from sort of
a an inner an inner dream or passion
that the founders had
I would say most of them are passion
driven now we we do have a few clients
who really
um recognized an opportunity and seized
it and they
um they're they are a little more like
separated from the emotional aspect of
the business but that's again and even
still as I think about those clients
that's what they say but yeah I would
challenge them that that actually there
really still is some passion there's
passion there's pride in it you started
something from nothing and you have
created something that is generating
well for not only yourself but for the
other people that work with and for you
sure that makes a lot of sense and so
going back to the different challenges
and complexities can we even break them
down even more so we met I mean
obviously we have the big
umbrellas of emotional personal Etc
let's break them down into how they come
to place in in the real world
absolutely
um so a lot of times what will happen is
and this is how we start off with all of
our clients we talk about being a
business first family or we talk about
being a family first business
so the differences between those or when
you're a business first family you're
going to take all of your family stuff
you're going to put it aside and you're
going to recognize that when you're
talking about the business the business
needs are going to come first so if it's
important to you as the owner of the
business and as the president of the
business that your son then carries on
that role regardless of their training
expertise experience that's going to be
a family first approach you're going to
be doing the interest of the family
first but if you're taking a business
first approach to that you're going to
say look you have the opportunity to get
this role but you're going to need to
have the experience for it as well
you're going to need to have the
qualifications for it so we start there
and so depend there's no right or wrong
right because the family that was my
next question right to live in their
truth their family need the family needs
living their treat we do have clients
where they do take the family first
approach that's often usually for like a
lifestyle business you know they're just
looking to maintain their lifestyle it's
less important to them that the business
has any kind of compounded revenue or
anything like that growth for the
business is not as important as steady
state and
maintaining a lifestyle for the business
owners
oftentimes though our our clients do go
the business
first route and so that then those
complications that you speak of that
start to come up are direction of the
business
sometimes it's generational
um
there is some disparity between you know
the two generations about what where
should the business go next what's going
to be the next big thing how are we
going to maintain our growth
um
what are the customers wanting you know
what's next
that's a huge one
um and so then it can also be
communication communication can be a big
issue because you develop patterns of
communicating within your family as you
grow up right and it's hard to break out
of those
you know kind of boxes that we put each
other in when we're 12.
um and then when you're 30
um it's hot it can be very challenging
for people to to see
their family members different
and I've kind of uh I I remember getting
very frustrated and I don't know another
way to describe us but I would get
frustrated when someone would refer to
us as like the kids and it's like oh
well gosh like we're old enough to have
our own kids now come on Quinn when do
we so it's it at times can be very
trivial and seem very
I don't know Petty when you're talking
to anyone else but it's like that
feeling of you want to be your own
person and you want to change you want
to be able to have the ability to change
and so communicating in those different
spaces can be really hard really really
hard
that makes a lot of sense and so you did
mention that there is no right or wrong
and every family has to live its truth
but now that we've
I mean we're all data driven right and
we can look at some case studies and
examples what is what have you found to
be more
resilient to I guess more more of the
emotional and personal conflicts that
that are probably some of the most
significant challenges that emerge here
which which approach
on a on a higher you know more generic
level do you find results in less of
these clashes
so definitely I would have to say
oh I think that I'm thinking about a
couple of different things but I think
that the number one thing that that we
see the most often has the best results
is that when people
are open to change when we are not
approaching the situation just as like
I'm right you're wrong this is why
um but when they're truly open to
exploring what's different and that's
something that's a conversation that we
have with clients all the time
especially like in our you know when
we're when a client's trying to
determine if they would like to work
with us you know we try to be very open
and honest in that it is a challenging
process and you do have to be willing to
do the work and be open to
changing your mind
um
certainly we recognize that we can't
change anyone that's not what we're out
to do but if you're going into the
process with the predetermined outcome
it's likely not going to work sure
um 100 that's the number one thing and
and we don't I can't think of a client
where we have that across the board my
personal experience wasn't like that my
father-in-law so I don't know if I
mentioned this yet or not but we were a
client of Ferguson Alliance before I'm
joined Ferguson alive
um and my father-in-law sought them out
and I remember thinking I don't have
time for this I don't have time to like
incorporate some other meeting into my
week you know we don't need that
um
I know we know everything that we need
to do why aren't we just doing that why
do we need somebody and it I probably
took that stance for the first probably
three months that that we started our
engagement but slowly over time I was
like oh
well I'm really starting to realize
there's a lot that I don't know and I
didn't know what I didn't know and so
um so that's not unusual because that
was me for sure
um
and so it is there is a process there is
just a period of time where you're kind
of trying like everyone's trying to get
aligned and and figure it out and so
yeah
never never has it been everyone fully
and ready what what happened in your
journey that led you to to transition
into the advising side after going
through perhaps the experience yourself
yeah that's a great question
um because I really feel like it's
important to also note too that in the
process new
you should ask yourself like what you
truly want and what I truly wanted while
I was all on board for a business first
family I wanted a family first family
and so I I said you know the best way
for me to do that is to
separate out where all of my energy is
going and so I really wanted to
to step outside of my operational duties
within the family business and then in
doing that
um I got the wonderful opportunity that
Ferguson Alliance wanted to have me join
their team and I'm very grateful for
that and I love love love that I get to
help people that
are are like me because it's not
something that is very well understood
um and it from the outside looking in
when you're working in a family business
it can look very glamorous and very
glorious and everyone gets the things
that like well you can just leave and go
and do whatever you need to do whenever
you need to do it like who's going to
stop you like what are they going to say
and sure you can run to the doctor like
when you need to go but also when it's 8
30 p.m on a Friday night and everyone
has worked the furthest away from their
mind it never leaves you as a family
member as a business owner it's always
there like it never leaves and so it
just takes a a different degree of
understanding
in a special type of person to
understand that and so I love having the
ability to be able to be that person for
somebody because it is
so needed
that's really really cool and it sounds
like you obviously are getting such a
such a jolt of energy from from this
work what do you think you know anybody
who's not even a certain necessarily a
family business but anybody working with
family members or good friends and I'm
now you know putting the putting
classifying those under a similar
category well what are some things that
that we can be that we can be thinking
about more tangibly and as we're going
through this journey yes I would say
family or friends or any any kind of
business partner relationship the best
thing I would say the best thing that
you can do and is the hardest to do is
to communicate and if you are bothered
by something and it's still so small and
then your default is to just Overlook it
let me tell you all those small things
pile up into big things and then three
four five years down the road when
you've just cannot haul that that giant
pile of little things around anymore
it's so much more challenging to
articulate
why you can't
rather than just
get in and out there taking the practice
having the hard conversation when they
are small allowing yourself that ability
to Pivot continually to where you're not
getting comfortable in these grooves and
then when it really is time that you
have to do something it's that much more
challenging because you do not have the
practice on how to have the hard
conversations and then you're trying to
have one big conversation about a
hundred little things it's so much right
right so much harder so
I would just say
yeah if there was things that I could go
back and do differently and be that
that's still you know no one no one
likes confrontation no one likes hard
conversations and then compounded this
is somebody that you love dearly and so
it makes it it makes it even harder but
just do it you will be better for it you
will be stronger for it it doesn't seem
like it in a lot of situations but you
really really will
what are the
um the benefits of working with family
members friends you know and then
perhaps obviously it may be more fun at
times but are there some significant
benefits that you see as you see
organizations working with people who
they know for many many years
oh yeah absolutely and I would say the
benefits far outweigh the challenges if
you're if you are working it right
because again the benefits of it can be
that you do know each other so well and
you can play into that and you can you
can
pivot of what I was talking about
pivoting but you can you can do it so
much easier and quicker than say if you
were just working in a in a nine to five
or working for like a corporation or
something like that oftentimes we see
this in all of our clients and it was
the same in my organization everyone
there feels like family you're creating
this this family culture where everyone
feels like that regardless of if they
are actually family or even friends of
of you everyone feels that and everyone
feels like they have
a place and a space to be more than just
the task that they're carrying out and I
would say that's the greatest thing
about it is that you can actually make
everyone feel like they're an
entrepreneur within your organization
everyone can feel like I mean I remember
like onboarding so many people in our
organization them just being amazed like
my father-in-law would be walking around
like asking them questions and really
taking their their input seriously and
people people were just so like thankful
and Amazed by that and that's just such
a small thing in the big scheme of
things I mean that's so tiny but the
impact is so huge that that people just
feel
purposeful by saying like hey I think
what if we did it this way instead of
this one
and I love it I think that that's
amazing I think that that's great and
you know not having so much of that
bureaucracy that can come with well I
need to ask my manager and then they
need to ask their manager and then we
have to get it approved up here and you
know by the time you hear back on it
you've lost your Steam on it you've got
another problem that you've got another
solution for that you're like well
what's the point how am I gonna
I'm gonna have to wait a month to hear
back and
so right I think it creates an amazing
energy where people
can feel part of something bigger than
just their paycheck
I love that that's really really cool
Brandy thank you so much for coming on
this was such an enjoyable time uh
wishing you best of luck with the rest
of your journey and thank you for the
positive impact you're making on people
and family businesses and thank you
again for joining me this was great oh
well thank you so much for having me
truly I love talking about this so I'm
very thankful for the opportunity
perfect thank you
[Music]